[Music]
I'm prepared to say that I have a record
of over 40
years and that I'm going to beat Joe
Biden
all right people I'm Dave Ruben this is
the Ruben report it's February 5th 2024
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and local share tap that notification
Bell if you have not and I should tell
you that there is no postgame show today
I've got 42 minutes to do this show
because immediately after we are hopping
in a car heading over to the airport
we're going to DC okay we have our
reasons yes that's right we're going
right to the swamp uh Rumble is opening
new Studios there tomorrow we will be in
studio all day long I'll be doing a live
show normal time 11:00 a.m. eastern uh
and then we have interviews with ran
Paul uh Ted Cruz Marsha Blackburn and a
whole bunch of other people we're trying
very hard to get John fedman I just
tweeted at him we've reached out through
the proper channels I want the one
saying Democrat so we're going to try to
do that too but Psy that rumbles opening
Studios over there uh but we're going to
do a bit of an abbreviated show and no
postgame show today but I will make it
up to you uh so let's just dive right
into it uh Bill Maher I've talked about
him once or twice on this show uh he had
he sits in that kind of last decent
liberal position and as I always say
when I play clips of billar we may never
get him to vote the right way but he has
a huge amount of what I would now say
are disaffected liberals who watch his
show and they go okay maybe he's not
going to get there uh but maybe I could
vote a little bit of a different way
maybe my trump derangement syndrome
isn't as in tents or maybe I'm realizing
oh I don't have the Comforts of you know
being worth 50 mil and whatever and I
don't and being a lifelong bachelor so I
can kind of keep my liberalism it's safe
in a little box but maybe I can move in
a way that he can't so anyway he had
Patrick bat David on uh the show the
other day and you know I'm always
talking about how there's this new
collection of people they're not really
right not really left they're into Free
Speech they get what's going on in the
world and they're all kind of Crossing
Lines and I'd say we're all right in the
middle of that so I was very happy to
see pbd uh go on the show and they
started talking about Gavin Nome and uh
unfortunately for Bill I don't think it
went that well do you like Nome how do
you feel about Nome had him on my show
Friday I saw that and uh I I first of
all I love him just you just like a guy
or you don't I've known him for a long
time he's done my show for a long time
do do I love everything he does as the
governor in California no I don't I
wouldn't say I'm undertaxed
uh yeah it's there I have issues with
this state he's a guy one reason I want
him to run for president well is cuz
he's obviously a winner this guy could
do it it's insane that we have the guy
but we can't run him because we have to
tiptoe around Biden and the final winner
well he would win the election oh so so
he would win the election he's a
talented debater speaker Communicator
deflector and politician and he's a
smart guy he's he's a smart real guy
with a pair of balls do I love
everything no you never know do with a
politician but first of all I think if
he ran for president it would be great
because it would force him to move to
the center now you're running not just
in California I mean this is California
it's weirdo will are you are you a are
you a uh are you a results striven guy
no I like to think watch Things Fall
Apart course you wouldn't build a show
that you win build and win at the levels
you won you know for decades if you
weren't results driven right I mean
you're you're you're Bill Mah you know I
what about what do you mean what's the
point about result exactly where I'm
going with you so results so results
driven guy right what areas has Nome won
in you said he's a winner winner of the
election he could win the election but
based on what do do you want results
like what has he done to California to
say he's a winner what what uh oh God I
don't know I it's
too Bill you're a smart you know what he
made it rain okay dude it wasn't raining
he said that he said great J it wasn't
raining and now it's raining so he's got
my vote respect I I don't know I don't
follow the
news I mean there's a lot there in the
end I don't know I don't follow the news
okay Bill again like I'm not going after
you personally I think this is actually
a net good when the decent liberals the
facade around the decent liberals gets
poked right because Bill you don't want
vaccine mandates and even though you
know he's like I don't know that I'm
taxed high enough in essence is what
he's saying it's like you know nothing's
working like pbd that's a that's a fine
job by pbd right there respectfully
being like well what are the good things
that he's done here and and Bill can't
come up with anything like the idea that
he wins elections all right if you win
elections but then you bring in wokeism
and you push Dei and you wreck the
economy and you cause 1.4 1.5 million
people to flee over three years three
years of back-to-back net loss of
migration in California right all of the
money and the resource that have left
the powerful people Joe Rogan Elon Musk
Ben Shapiro who have left like at some
point like Bill you got to come up with
something I would say that Patrick had a
bit of an advantage there because I
don't think he was stoned and Bill was
anyway one more clip uh with two of them
related to uh Trump and vaccines because
it's a lot of force and you better we
know what's right for you and you don't
there is no reason on the left oh that
sweetheart you are preaching in the
converted here this is I'm always
bitching about this
um I do not you're supporting Biden
though of course because we only get two
choices I mean what is so hard to
understand about about bad and worse
they forced America to take the vaccine
Bill 70% Americans took the vaccine and
didn't want to take it a lot of them
didn't wait wa wait a second when did
the vaccine come about under Biden no
under Trump no no it didn't came two
days after election was over with two
days after election was over with if
fizer announced it was not under under
Trump they intentionally kep the vaccine
after the election so they gave the
victory to that's right okay so again
that's just a nice Moment by P pbd just
giving facts and I want to give some
credit to bill because I know I'm poking
bill here but Bill keeps having these
conversations so again as I always say
it doesn't matter if Bill gets the end
but he is willing to have these
conversations and it's good like when he
brought me on his show which is almost
two years ago now and he said the thing
about how Hillary had never said there
was an illegitimate election and I was
like yes she actually tweeted it and you
could see maybe he woke up a little bit
to some degree or when I went on Real
Time a couple weeks ago two months ago
and I said and I debunked right in front
of his face and his entire audience face
uh the Donald Trump very fine people on
his whole uh very fine people on both
sides hoax so look nobody's hands are
clean when it comes to covid and
vaccines and everything else but the
truth is that Donald Trump did push
through warp speed but then he was not
for mandates it was Joe Biden who was
for Mand and caused all of the doctors
and nurses to be fired in corporations
with over a thousand people to fire
people and all of the rest of it so once
again it's one of those things where
it's like Bill you you hate the mandates
and the vaccines and all that stuff but
you are supporting the guy and and when
you say well it's only a binary choice
we only have these two people well there
was another guy you even interviewed him
on your show Ronda santis who you could
have said was more of a decent
Republican but in a weird way the media
liberals want Trump right they think
he's the most defeat but he's also good
for the views but all the point of all
of this is this is a good thing to see
because I think what pbd is doing there
is he's just calmly laying out a way
that people can come back to sanity
right it's what I try to do here and I
think more and more people are seeing
that actually I have proof because uh we
we are now it probably will happen today
our YouTube channel is going to hit its
1 billionth View and last month was not
only our biggest month ever but like we
we more than doubled our previously
highest held month so people do want to
wake up I meant to mention that up top
uh anyway we're going to connect this to
a whole bunch of other stuff speaking
about waking up and this border crisis
that we have and the fact that we're
heading to DC tomorrow as they're about
to vote on this crazy Bill uh but before
we get to that let me talk to you guys
about the wellness company guys this a
2020 all over again it's an election
year after all remember event 201 in
October of 2019 and what happened when a
couple months later when covid-19
started sweeping the headlines in
January well the wef overlords met
January 1 and disease X was on the
docket we covered it the wef's website
states with fresh warnings from the wh
that an unknown disease X could result
in 20 times more fatalities than the
Corona virus pandemic what novel efforts
are needed to prepare Health Care
Systems for the multiple challenges
ahead they got us in 2020 but no matter
what's coming in 24 the most important
thing you can do is be prepared ahead of
time with food ammo gold and medications
that's where the wellness company's
medical emergency kit comes in avoid
Hospital weight time stimes avoid the
cost of a doctor's visit or calling an
ambulance avoid getting caught
unexpectedly when traveling without a
health care plan the wellness company's
medical emergency kit offers eight
life-saving medications including
moxacin zpac and ivermectin for you to
keep on hand along with a guide book for
safe use from tick bites to covid to
extreme biot Terror events every
scenario is covered go to tww c. health
rubben and grab your emergency medical
kit right now that's tww c. rubben uh
code ruin which will give you 15% at
checkout don't wait until you need it
take back control of your health today
with the wellness company's medical
emergency kit kits are only available in
the USA and now back to me all right
so banged around Bill Maher a little bit
gently didn't stab you didn't turn the
knife anything like that but now I'd
like to give Bill a little credit
because on his main program real time uh
bill is getting it when it comes to the
Democrat nonsense around the border the
fact that right this very moment
the president who only weeks ago his
entire clown Administration was saying
there's no crisis of order now they're
all acknowledging there's a crisis at
the border but they're pretending still
that Biden can't just fix it right now
well bill called him out on that part
two of the acting is Jo is is Joe Biden
saying you know what if you just give me
a new law a new law why doesn't the
president conf fix this he already has
the existing laws
border I need a piece of paper from
Congress to deal with the Border no you
already have that that's
that's all right so now again bill you
are supporting the guy and you voted for
the guy last time so you have to think
about that I suppose but that is good he
is saying to his liberal audience that
we want to get there and they some of
them get there in slowmo he's saying to
them Biden can fix this freaking thing
right now it's on Biden it's not on the
Republicans but speaking of Republicans
Republican leader Mike Johnson uh he
tweeted out that clip and he wrote this
even Bill Maher gets it President Biden
Absol abolutely has the authority right
now to fix the catastrophe he's created
at the border and that is absolutely
true right you guys know it one of those
very few things that the federal
government is supposed to do is protect
the Border not only are they not
protecting the border now they are in a
fight with the states specifically Texas
but it's going to come to all the border
states and then it'll come to the
non-border states too when they are
trying to do something about the Border
because the federal government will not
do their job here is Speaker Johnson on
NBC once again explaining Biden you
could do this right now we don't need
more paper we don't need more signatures
or anything else you can fix this
freaking thing right this very moment
has to be secured the president has the
authority right now he doesn't need
another act of Congress he could do it
right now but he's unwilling to do it as
you know the White House
has completely dismissed the allegation
that in any way the migrants and surgeon
migrants have been intentional on the
part of the president in terms of being
able to take action right now Mr Speaker
you know as well as I do that an
executive order would only be met by
legal challenges you have a chance to do
something right now the details we laid
out are not rumors that is based on
negotiators who were in the room does
she strike you as a journalist or an
activist for the Democrat Party we know
damn well Biden can do this there are no
more laws we need there are laws on the
books that say you cannot have an open
border okay uh the president can do an
awful lot by executive action if we
needed to do something more and not that
I'm for executive actions it's complete
nonsense we already went through this
bill with you guys last week the bill
which says that they will still allow in
5,000 illegals every day so it's a bill
we're going to sign a bill and also
we'll tell people how many of them can
break this law every single day 1.8
million people a year but if so anyway
I'm going to DC tomorrow I I mentioned
some of the Senators and Congress people
will be interviewing and I'm going to
hold all of their feet to the fire on
this thing I mean if any of them sign on
to this thing it is an absolute disaster
and by the way the Democrats have more
disasters waiting this this one is wild
uh from n wokeness uh breaking 150
Democrats vote against the bill to
deport illegals caught driving while
drunk here's representative prila jaipal
she's in the Hamas caucus and uh rather
than being concerned about the amount of
illegals coming here and the crime that
we're seeing on our streets and they're
kicking homeless people out of shelters
and the fenel and all that she's very
upset that we keep calling these people
illegals we really saying that we think
the best use of our very limited federal
government resources is to work on
deporting a green card holder who
decided to sleep in their car rather
than drive home drunk from a bar a green
card holder not trying to drive drunk
just trying to stay warm I certainly
don't think that's a good use of our
resources it's certainly not a good use
of our time on this floor but my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have made it clear that they're
not interested in sensible Solutions
just in
sensationalism this bill is another
example of that and I hope my colleagues
will stop referring to people as
illegals people are human beings they
have different statuses some are
undocumented mented if you want to say
some are illegal but let's not call
human beings illegal tired of that
language I urge my colleagues to reject
this Bild and I yield back the balance
of they are illegal and I have some
language that I can't say about you but
I'm going to write on this piece of
paper and I'm going to send it to
someone in locals you know what I wrote
It's that word that's what I wrote here
and I'm going to sign it Dave Rubin and
we're going to send it to somebody on
locals um did you also catch the fact
that she wants she's encouraging people
green cards to drive drunk on top of
everything else these people are
absolutely extraordinary they are
illegal they should not be here we can
talk about Pathway to citizenship we got
to close the border but the Democrats
are here to destroy the country yes
there are five or six semian ones and I
will keep encouraging them to come to
the promised land but like they are here
to destroy everything you want more
evidence of it well we showed you the
video last week of two police officers
having the kicked out of them by a
bunch of illegals sui jaipal uh and uh
of course then they were taken into
custody and and I think we've got an
image of them taken into custody where
they seem like nice fellas they were
just you know they were just partying
just having fun on the streets of New
York City uh here's video of them
leaving because they were arrested for a
moment and then immediately released
they kicked the crap out of a bunch of
New York City police officers I guess
that's not a problem anymore so here's
video of them walking out just into Fox
News Now NYPD making two more arrests
illegal immig
and that attack on officers those
suspects also allegedly stole an officer
cell phone well that'll help them track
you down so a fifth illegal immigrant
accused of attacking two New York City
police officers over the weekend showed
no remorse or
regret he was seen as you can see giving
his two middle fingers to the cameras
moments after being released without
bail I mean it's extraordinary right
like if this was a movie you'd be be
like there would be no way that anyone
would be so Brazen to be flipping off
the camera and the guy that's not hiding
his face and why were they let out so
you might go okay why were they let out
if this story can't be real well the
district attorney of New York his name
is Alvin Bragg and you might know that
name because he's one of the guys going
after Donald Trump for a multitude of
nonsensical issues uh we've got a tweet
here from Colin rug explaining what the
District Attorney's plan is New York
City district attorney Alvin Bragg is
defending his decision to let the
illegals go who allegedly beat up the
NYPD Officer says the video evidence
wasn't enough insane the illegal
immigrants involved in the incident have
since reportedly fled to California in a
court of law our profound obligation is
to make sure we have right people
charged with the right crimes I don't
think New Yorkers want to charge the
wrong person brag said there is a
presumption of pre-trial non-
incarceration for every case except
those with charges of homicide or the
death of a victim okay guys first off
nobody is debating whether it's those
five people we just showed you in the in
that image whether those were the people
that beat up the cops those are the
people who beat up the cops nobody's
debating it okay I suppose brag is
debating it nobody else is debating it
they clearly are emboldened they walk
out of the the police station and
they're flipping the bird to everybody
and then of course where did they go
congratulations California you've got
five more future voters if you think
that the insanity of New York could not
get worse well I have a bridge I'd like
to sell you and it's filled with legals
um this is what's going on in New York
City right now this is wild uh from the
New York Post New York City launches 53
million program to hand out prepaid
credit cards to migrant families so they
are now going to take more of the
taxpayer money and by the way they're a
taxpayer base in New York City it's
getting less and less because they're
all freaking moving down all the
successful people who pay all the taxes
are getting the hell out of that
hole and they're moving down to Florida
and to Texas and to Tennessee but
they're then squeezing they put the
squeeze on the remaining sane people
we're going to take more oh you you get
you work for a living you abide by the
law you don't jump the Turn Style you're
screwed mfer we're going to take more of
your money and we're going to hand it to
those people and they kick the crap out
of the
cops okay but you might say Dave Dave
Dave that's just New York City it's New
York City that's crazy it's not the
whole state that's crazy well I'd like
to introduce you to a woman named Kathy
hokel who is the governor of uh New York
and uh she has sort of expanded this
throughout New York City it's happening
everywhere so check this out this is
wild this is CNN they're analyzing
what's going on with these migrants and
why they do this in New York and why it
only happens in these blue cities and
states check this out the back you don't
you don't touch our police officers you
don't touch anybody thank you everybody
I mean we're hearing a change when it
comes to immigration in general from
president Biden on down do you hear her
talk about that it is also directly
related to the fact that these were
police officers does that have any
impact does that change anything well
it's so complicated because you know
you're a New Yorker you move through the
city every day as I do we see these
people we touch these people they're out
looking for work they're delivering our
food they're at the gas stations and the
car wash um I mean these are people who
came in waves you know 170,000 probably
to New York City um but within that
group this hardworking you know throngs
of people in search of Hope and a better
life there is this 1center you know
criminal element that looks at a
different opportunity here these
individuals I went over their wrap
sheets yesterday multiple charges Grand
larsy robbery attempted robbery grand
larsy grand larsy uh this particular
crew operated on mopeds and scooters
they were doing organized retail theft
they were doing snatches on the street
iPhones iPads clothing so on and so
forth um one of them that they are still
seeking has 10 charges on one day
because he's part of a pattern that's
been going on and I'm looking at the
dates that their arrest started which is
probably close to when they got here
they've only been here a couple of
months so what the detectives are
telling me is they have Crews here that
operate in New York do all their
stealing then go to Florida to spend the
money and then come back and I'm like
well why don't they just stay in steel
in Florida and they said cuz there you
go to jail oh
great rep keep
us fa point oh but what jail laws I
can't believe it Florida and then they
go back to New York to steal again so I
guess as a Floridian I should thank
these people keep doing it hoko go for
it Adams open up all of your stores let
them steal all your stuff allow them to
come down here Aron well I don't want
them down here but you can see the you
can see the logic in it spend all your
cash down here try to steal some pants
at Lululemon and get your brains blown
out that would be just fine but we'd
rather you just go back and keep doing
it but that's how ridiculous this entire
thing is by the way the the guy there
who is uh who said that another an
interesting piece of this is the liberal
the guilty mind of the liberal where
he's like you know there's 170,000 of
these people and many of them are good
and blah blah blah it's these gangs and
by the way he is making a point of
saying that they know exactly who kicked
the crap out of the cops so again Alvin
brg is just outright lying there when he
says the video evidence is not enough
they know exactly what they're doing
where they came from and everything else
and congratul once again to California
CU you've got five five more of them um
but his point about you know most of
them are hardworking and blah blah blah
and it's only these criminals it doesn't
matter we don't know who they are we
don't you're not allowed to come here
illegally anyway that is the original
sin right we can deal with all but some
of them are very nice okay so we can try
to figure some of that out but not until
we deal with the root cause of the
problem which you people keep making
worse but now let's get to some
solutions because yes that Florida place
that they mentioned where we have Law
and Order and you're not allowed to
steal stuff and we don't let illegals in
and actually if you do get here we're
going to send you up to Martha's
Vineyard and everything else well it's
because in large part of a guy named
Ronda santis who ran for president it
did not work out but I got to tell you
in light of the news in the last three
weeks or so I am very happy that he will
remain the governor down here and here
he is calling out some of this pure BS
and you see some of these images you see
some of these people in New York City
committing crimes and the sense of
entitlement on some of these illegal
aliens is unbelievable they act like
they have a right to illegally come into
our country I'm sorry you do not have
that right and if we were a country that
was serious we'd be sending these people
back home to their home countries that's
how you enforce the rule of law Biden's
not doing that he could secure the
Border if he wanted to um and he's
choosing not to do it so I don't think
they're going to end up with any type of
legislation that's going to actually
solve the problem I think in some
respects it may C y the the problems and
and kind of give Biden a campaign issue
to where he says oh well they wouldn't
give me the authority he has the
authority now uh if he if he wanted to
do it he could do it as always the guy's
just laying out the truth saying it how
it is and saying how he would do things
differently what he's referring to at
the end there of course is this
ridiculous Bill and so that is great to
see Ronda santis he's not a he's not a
congressman anymore he's not a senator
he's the governor so it's not like he's
going to vote on this thing but he's
making a point and saying this bill is
pure BS and if you throw Biden a bone
here yes we'll have a bipartisan bill
and the bipartisan bill will allow 1.8
million illegals in per year you're
actually handing Biden something it's
just all complete nonsense so it is good
to see Ronda santis back down here
wielding political power like a boss
like the way he was doing it before the
campaign uh and by the way the a bunch
of red State uh Governors are helping
out in Texas of course that's Greg
Abbott's moved down there to fight the
federal government on this but Florida
we're stepping up this is this is
beautiful check it out we have stepped
up probably more than any other state
has stepped up and we're proud to do
that however uh we don't think this is
enough uh I believe that a state has a
right to fortify its own borders uh and
so if Texas is helping to erect barriers
putting up razor wire doing other things
to keep illegal aliens out I want to be
help ful with them doing that I don't
want to be part of the federal
government trying to tear down these
barriers and let more people in
illegally this is crazy that this is the
case uh so today uh we are going to
fortify our presence along the southern
border uh we're providing up to one
battalion of Florida National Guard uh
as well as uh our first ever deployment
of the Florida State guard and the goal
is to help Texas
fortify this border help them strengthen
the barricades help them add barriers
help them add the wire that they need to
so that we can stop this Invasion once
and for all and the states have to yeah
that's right everything there is right
that's how we do this the states have to
do this the federal government did not
create the states the States created the
Federal Government the federal
government is now in in complete der
elction of its Duty it is exacerbating a
problem and these dingbats and Congress
and the Senate are are only going to
make it worse there is no such thing as
a bipar is in deal right now it's not a
yes you might get enough people to sign
it so you can say it's bipartisan but if
it's just going to make this thing worse
and as the santis referenced in the
earlier clip codify the nonsense right
Biden will be able to take that to the
voters and see you see it's not just my
fault we have a bipartisan bill so it's
obviously the Republican's fault too so
yes it is beautiful to see that in
Florida uh that Battalion it's about a
thousand troops that we are going to
send over to to Texas to help and by the
way that's in Florida's own
self-interest right if the border is
poorest in Texas mostly also Arizona Etc
but it's like okay if we can stop it
there then those people won't get to
Florida Florida has other uh benefits uh
and advantages because we're a peninsula
and we've got a coast guard so you know
he's doing everything he can so good
people are stepping up so you call out
the nonsense you you you fight for
what's right and then actually do
something about it rather than just
complaining about scary words so I want
to throw back to that Gile clip for just
a moment and I hope my colleagues will
stop referring to people as elegal
people are human beings they have
different statuses some are undocumented
if you want to say some are illegal but
let's not call human beings illegal
tired of that language I urge my
colleagues to reject this bill and I
yield back the balance of so that's
someone who doesn't want to solve a
problem and who wants to go out of their
way to demonize everyone who does want
want to solve a problem now jaipal and
the and the wackadoodle progressives
that are for all this who hate the
country in the first place I mean they
tell you they hate the founding of the
country the country is systemically
racist and everything what she's doing
there in in a bizarre way is is it's not
that clever anymore because a lot of
people get it but what she's trying to
do there is she's saying they but if you
call them illegal what you're doing is
dehumanizing them and you can't
dehumanize people because they're the
oppressed and if they're oppressed well
then you're the oppressor and just wait
till someone like jaipal and the rest of
her homas caucus friends have the power
to do the oppressing they are they are
not going to be too kind to you me or
anyone that we know and I think we can
connect this to many things in history
there was a great podcast a couple days
ago Jordan Peterson it was two two of my
Allstars Jordan Peterson and Michael
malice talking about this oppressed
oppressor narrative and what societies
will do when things start getting out of
whack what happened in Rwanda even
though it was quite a peaceful State
although poor was that the notion of
group identity became Paramount and then
one ethnic group was set against the
other and what happened in Rwanda is
reminiscent of the sorts of things
perhaps faster and even more brutal
possibly than what happened in the
Soviet Union a mill million people
killed in a span of mere months right in
the most brutal possible way was a
consequence of the valorization of group
identity you saw the same thing
happening in Russia right because and
this happened soon after the revolution
is that the the Communists were
attempting to eradicate bisi
individuality and so people started to
be classified and judged by group guilt
and then almost immediately after the
revolution if you were a land owner or
property owner or anybody who' had even
a modicum of success under the Zars or
your family or your well that's the next
thing you were classified as an
oppressor and as an enemy of the people
but immediately it spread to your family
even if you didn't own anything if you
had people in your ancestry who ever
dared to own anything which meant
everyone who was even vaguely they
identified success with oppression you
know which is something that we're
trying very hard to do in our culture at
the moment too which is absolutely
catastrophic we're doing the same bloody
things right dividing people into groups
making group identity Paramount
identifying success itself with with
oppression so do you see do you see what
they are doing they are the oppressed we
are the oppressors and they are trying
to upend the system they want to bring
in as many people as they can control
and they can bring in more voters this
is not a grand conspiracy theory or
anything else just remember it was only
until about two weeks ago that the
Democrats and the mainstream media even
acknowledged there was an issue at the
border a whole bunch of us have been
talking about it for a year right and it
was bubbling up mostly on Twitter thanks
to Elon Musk for a year I I've shown you
a million videos of Karin Jean Pierre
and before her Jen Saki and Biden
himself and Cala and all these people
there's no problem at the border The
Border's secure blah blah blah but a
whole bunch of
us we started ringing the bells right
then they start paying attention now
they're acknowledging there's a problem
and we damn well better do something
about it now it might be too late but if
we don't start doing something about it
now at least to delay the the insanity
then what Jordan is laying out there
will Happ happen here we will have
sectarian violence on our streets we
will have religious violence on our
streets we have no idea the motives of
these people that have come in and
especially in light of all of the world
events since October 7th like there's
some problems so so what is the solution
well I think the solution partly is what
pbd set up top right you call out the
people who are mistaken about certain
issues so Mar you like Gavin Newsome
well tell me some of the things he did
and then you can sort of watch it happen
in real time where Bill doesn't know you
can look at someone like Rona santis who
goes out there and does everything he
says he's going to do and then creates a
state that's Rock Solid so now he can
help other states uh do that same thing
right that blueprint and then this is
this is a great story there was an
election yesterday in El Salvador and
the current president naib buk won
re-election by like 85
87% this guy has turned El Salvador
which was one of the most dangerous gang
run countries in the entire world uh he
is turned it into a real gem at the
moment where they are getting ton of
economic activity and safety the whole
country is changing around I actually
went to El Salvador a couple years ago
my brother-in-law was living there and
he was doing some some volunteer work
down there and and they had to have the
Americans had to live in a little
Community with a lot of barbed wire a
lot of barbed wire and you weren't
allowed to go outside because you know
barbed wire works somebody should tell
that to Joe Biden anyway uh naib buelli
who just won in an absolute Landslide he
crushed the the gangs and everything
else uh he uh he gave a little talk
about uh how we should start doing
things right so that the right people
the good people the citizens are
rewarded instead of always looking out
for other people how about we look out
for
[Music]
ourselves
EX
for
e
for those of you listening on the audio
podcast who don't speak English he
basically said jaipal is wrong that was
the thrust of it uh the thrust of it is
stop as sane societies caring about
people who don't care about you stop
treating illegals as if they are better
or more worthy of resources and
everything else then the legal people
who are in these countries paying taxes
doing the right thing how about you
start all of us whether it's down in El
Salvador it's here in the United States
or it's across the pond in the UK how
about start caring about the people who
are in your civilizations who have built
your culture and built your buildings
and built your societies and expanded
more freedoms than you can possibly
freaking imagine imagine if government
started working for those people instead
of having people like praya jaipal who's
mostly concerned that we're calling
illegal people illegal the choice is
yours ladies and gentlemen with all of
that being said I'm off to the swamp
that's right we're going to DC bunch of
interviews tomorrow but we will be live
from the brand new Rumble Studios uh at
11:00 a.m. as always my full interview
which is really Catching Fire Elon
tweeted out uh with Dr Drew is up right
now and
uh I guess oh so no postgame show and uh
I leave you with my thoughts about going
to DC goodbye you will never find the
more wretched Hive of scum and
villainy we must be
cautious